bonjour adrien taille toujours pas
recommencé
ont commencé les déplacés les débats
merci beaucoup d'être invités politiques
sur le matin vous êtes secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enfance et des familles on
va bien sûr longuement parlé de votre
texte dont on a déjà parlé avec le
rapporteur mais c'est important
évidemment d'en parler avec vous mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est la crise
sanitaire et des questions qui se posent
autour de la vaccination des enfants on
attend l'avis des autorités sanitaires
dans les prochains jours est ce que pour
vous la vaccination des enfants elle est
indispensable pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
alors le premier ministe vous l'avez
entendu à parler de nécessiter un je
crois enfin deux ans fonctionnaire il ya
déjà eu d un avis de la haute autorité
de santé a notamment sur les anciens les
plus pour les enfants les plus
vulnérables et d'ailleurs campagne de
vaccination pour ces trois cent soixante
mille enfants atteints de maladies
chroniques de cancers etc a débuté
aujourd'hui il est important pour les
protéger
effectivement cette vaccination puisse
avoir lieu pour le reste des quasi 6
millions d'autres enfants âgés de 5 à 11
ans je pense effectivement
qu'il est important de pouvoir de
pouvoir les vacciner on parle beaucoup
ces mêmes leurs critères importants du
bénéfice risque elle bénéfice risque
collectif qu'on met souvent en avant il
est important parce que c'est vrai qu'on
le sait plus un virus eux circulent plus
des daevas riom peuvent se développer
mais je crois quand même que s'agissant
les enfants c'est quand même quand même
question du bénéfice risque et donc du
bénéfice individuel pour parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'un certain nombre
d'enfants quand même très petit nombre
forte heureusement qu'ils développent
des formes graves il ya des enfants ce
fameux pim cela ces inflammations
myocarde ces quelques dizaines d'enfants
mais c'est quand même des enfants qui
connaissent des formes sévères il faut
les protéger et puis on n'a pas de recul
aujourd'hui sur sur les effets du co vie
de long sur les enfants on sait que sur
les adultes c'est le cas donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que pour les
protéger au 6e c'est pas juste ce n'est
pas juste un bénéfice altruiste je pense
que pour les protéger eux aussi il est
important effectivement pouvoir vacciner
les enfants entre cinq ans avait mangé
deux enfants de moins de 11 j'en ai
parlé avec eux et quand ça sera ouvert
avec snecma femmes sauf que précisément
quand vous parlez de bénéfices risques
on sait que pour les petits à fortiori
pour les pubs les plus petits d'entre
eux on peut se poser la question si y'a
pas plus d'inconvénients liés au vaccin
potentiellement que de protection réelle
contre la maladie vous parlez de
quelques dizaines de cas on sait que les
formes sévères graves existent pour les
enfants mais elles sont vraiment très
très près de brit air absolument mais
une fois encore il y en a un et puis
c'est de développer des effets
secondaires que d'être protégés dans la
maladie les ses formes graves depuis le
site depuis le début mois le
gouvernement nous reposons sur sur les
avis des autorités de santé et les
autorités scientifiques et elles
parviennent à vous rassurer vous êtes
complète à oui on est on est on est
effectivement on suit on a suivi le
satisfont les enfants vous savez qu'il
eut des premiers essais cliniques qui
ont été faits qui ont fondé les premiers
les avis des différentes autorités de
senneterre qu'elles soient américaines
européennes françaises avec la haute
autorité de santé le contest conseil
d'orientation vaccinale et puis on
attend là dans les jours à venir
d'autres résultats un peu en population
réelle j'ai envie de dire puisque vous
le savez il ya un certain nombre de pays
qui sont qui ont été plus en avance
pionniers sa vaccination des enfants par
rapport à la france c'est le cas des
états unis d'israël par exemple et donc
sur des graines de 4 millions d'enfants
je crois s'agissant des états unis on va
avoir des données aussi réelles sur des
très très grande porte sur les éric là
bas c'est ça qui va fonder aussi les
décisions à venir on y va on va parce
qu'on va pas se mentir on y va tout
droit vous allez imposer la vaccination
obligatoire pour les plus de cinq ans à
écouter obligatoires enfin
pardon excusez moi
très important mais vous allez demander
à ce que les enfants cinq ans soient
tous vaccinés jeudi va dire on irait
direct je vais pas faire de danon ça
avant les annonces et laisser la primeur
de danone éventuels ont fait encore au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier véran premier ministre il ya
déjà été décidé d'ouvrir la vaccination
pour les enfants fragiles ça commence
aujourd'hui ça c'est une certitude on
attend les décisions des autorités de
santé pour la tenir le coup c'est pour
ces imminents écoutez je crois qu'on
enfin on a dit que on se mettait en
capacité de pouvoir ouvrir la
vaccination non obligatoire volontaire
je me permets de le ré insisté là dessus
d'ici la fin de l'année voilà et puis il
ya déjà ça veut dire une campagne qui va
être lancée massivement si elle est
ouverte est-ce qu'il faut pouvoir
vacciner les enfants dans leur école
écoutez la stratégie aujourd'hui qui est
développée est d'une part et la question
des doses de vaccins c'est que ce sont
pas les bonnes doses par an on peut
comprendre que les adultes il ya des
commandes de doses qui ont été effectués
pour les mois de décembre de janvier qui
vont permettre de lancer une
conversation si tenté une fois encore
quelle qu'elle soit actée et c'est dans
un premier temps dans des centres de
vaccination qui seront dédiés aux
enfants enfin avec des avec des fils
détiennent
c'est là en tout cas dans un premier
temps c'est la stratégie de vaccination
qui a été mis en émoi la tuque puisque
le conseil scientifique a
annoncée quelques recommandations
hilaire en vue des fêtes mais aussi le
redoute une croissance forte du variant
omicron en france dans les prochaines
semaines est ce que pour les enfants les
écoles pourront continuer à être ouverte
dans ces cas là vous savez que c'est une
préoccupation de priorités même de tout
gouvernement du président de la
république même mais le gouvernement
tout entier depuis le début de
l'épidémie de faire en sorte que les
écoles puissent rester ouverte c'est
qu'il ya de plus en plus de classes
fermées est-ce que c'est pas compliqué
pour les enfants
écoutez on pense une grande fierté que
d'avoir pu laisser les écoles ouvertes
puisqu'on parlait de concept de risque
aussi et de deux désavantages pour les
enfants liés à l'épidémie va le fait de
ne pas pouvoir aller à l'école on fait
partie 1
donc nous faut continuons de tout faire
pour que les écoles restent ouverts mais
c'est c'est en cela que la stratégie
globale pas que des enfants global de
vaccination vaccination vaccination
d'une part et puis
gestes-barrières parce que juste mais là
on sait très bien la remontée de
l'épidémie à ces dernières semaines
n'est pas lié au nouveau variant au
micron il est lié au fait qu'on a un peu
relâché les nos gestes barrières et que
c'est le variant delta kaki qui repart à
la hausse donc voilà c'est pour ça que
je tu penses masse c'est pour ça qu'on
doit retrouver nos dissociation physique
un peu plus un peu plus raisonnable
c'est pour ça qu'on va faire attention
profitez de ces fêtes de fin d'année de
façon heureuse sereine parce qu'on sort
de deux années
compliquées on est fatigué mais il faut
quand même être être vigilant traîne on
va parler de votre texte le texte sur la
protection des enfants qui arrivent du
sénat cet après midi l'objectif de ce
texte vous c'est d'améliorer la sécurité
affective matériels et physiques des
enfants placés qu'est ce qui manquait
jusque
alors il ya deux voulez vous l'avez
évoqué avec werner von juste avant ma
société je l'inscris très volontiers
dans la lignée des textes de sénateurs
qui ont été ministres par le passé
philippe bas qui a porté un texte en
2007 et laurence rossignol
il ya un qui a porté la loi de 2016 avec
michel meunier qui était sénatrice à
l'époque donc on voit bien que c'est un
sujet aussi qui est qui et trans
partisan je pense ces deux ans
d'ailleurs je travaille avec le sénat et
avec eux avec le rapporteur bonne avec
l'ensemble des groupes pour essayer de
faire avancer
il ya un certain nombre de sujets
d'effectivité des lois précédentes et
puis il ya un certain nombre de choses à
améliorer il faut renforcer la sécurité
physique
vous l'avez évoqué il faut davantage de
contrôles il faut qu' il ya une culture
de la sécurité physique des enfants dans
les établissements dans la relation
entre les départements et les
établissements il faut créer des
référents
externe tiers pour garantir la sécurité
des enfants on va créer une base
nationale des agréments pour les
assistants familiaux pour éviter ça
n'arrive pas tous les quatre matins
c'est marginal mais ça a pu arriver par
le passé et ça a conduit à des choses
dramatiques qu'un assistant familial qui
avaient commis des maltraitances
changent de département et on sait que
c'est une compétence départementalisée
donc il pouvait sortir des radars bon là
certain nombre de choses enfin ça et
puis sécurité affective on sait que
c'est
important pour penser enfants là et à
cet égard et un certain nombre de
dispositions importantes d'une première
disposition sertic premier d'ailleurs
qui peut vraiment changer notre système
sur le sur le moyen terme qui va
consister à ce que les travailleurs
sociaux et les juges avant de placer un
enfant recherche il n'ya pas à ce qu'on
appelle un tiers digne de confiance
qu'ils puissent prendre en charge
l'enfant - c'est un tiers des courriers
que je reçois un ministère qui concerne
l'aide sociale à l'enfance ce sont des
tentes des grands parents etc ractis
mais moi je ne comprends pas mon petit
fils mon neveu a été placée alors que
j'aurais pu m'en j'aurais pu m'en
occuper voilà donc on va on va
développer ça il faut aussi l'encadré
l'accompagnait parce que c'est pas rien
2 poids 2 devrait être s'occuper d'un
enfant comme ça comme si c'était son
propre enfant même ça c'est quelque
chose d'important on interdit la
séparation des fratries ça aussi c'est
important en termes de dossiers et on
essaye de démultiplier de renforcer ses
liens quand vous réussissez comment vous
vous êtes construit dans votre vie vous
êtes vous êtes construit au travers de
multiples liens d'attachement et pas que
votre père votre mairie et plein
d'autres personnes voilà donc on va
rendre obligatoire par exemple le
parrainage pour tous ces enfants le
mentorat aussi pour l'accompagnement
scolaire mais aussi l'insertion
professionnelle va tout un ensemble
dispositif pour renforcer cette sécurité
je ne veux pas dire d'effectivité des
lois précédentes y ait un seul un tiers
des départements qui mettait en oeuvre
un projet pour l'enfant
dans les lois pourquoi de commandes
expliquer de telles disparités entre les
départements écoutez ce que je vois en
tout cas c'est que depuis qu'il y ait un
secrétariat d'état à l'enfance depuis
qu'on a remis ce sujet un peu en haut de
l'agenda nous jeudi les pouvoirs publics
d'autres les associations et 7 à 20 h 20
ans aucun aucun monopole de la chose
depuis qu'on a contractualisé aussi
parce que vous savez là on est là on
parle de la loi mais ce n'est qu'elle
est en fait ce n'est que la brique
législatives d'une stratégie de
prévention de protection de l'enfance
qu'on a collaboré avec les différents
acteurs les départements les
associations il ya trois ans et qu'on
déploie depuis sur lequel il ya
notamment une phase une part dans un
volet de contractualisation un peu sur
le modèle du plan pauvreté houle et à
contractualiser avec les départements
sur des objectifs en trois ans l'état a
mis plus de 600 millions de gens tant
que vous parliez de financement et je
sais que vers narbonne va me faire les
financements cet après midi ne sera pas
le seul et j'aurai des réponses à lui à
lui apporter à cet égard est une réponse
déjà repris en ce sens et que l'état
déjà ces trois dernières années a mis
600 millions d'euros sur la protection
de l'enfance dont 100 millions d'euros
sur les pmi protection maternelle et
infantile qui sont instances du
département mais auquel moi je crois
beaucoup parce que ces instances de
prévention je lis prévention et et
protection
bah écoutez je laisser la primeur si
vous m'y a autorisé des ces annonces aux
sénateurs cet après midi donc vous allez
vous écouterez
prévu une fois encore il ya déjà des gir
il ya déjà des choses dans les 600
millions d'euros que j'évoque par
exemple je vous parlais de parrainage ça
permet de financer le panache ça permet
de créer des places donc pour notamment
sa nombre de départements n'ont pas
dispositif aujourd'hui pour ne pas
séparer les fratries et bien grâce à
l'argent qu'on a mis dans le cas de la
contractualisation ils vont pouvoir
créer des places dans que oui on
anticipe par anticipation en quelque
sorte il ya déjà des financements
et puis il ya quelques financements
complémentaires qui sont apportées
notamment pour un aspect important du
texte aussi exigé entendu ou delavier
évoquer ces sujets critiques qu'essuie
de la question des sorties du dispositif
de l'avenir mais juste sur les
financements parce que vous avez là
dessus notamment entendu thermo midi il
faut pas que ça soit à la charge des
départements les départements ils sont
déjà exemple ils n'ont pas besoin de
charges supplémentaires il faut que ce
soit l'état qui prennent en charge tout
ça ça va dans ce sens bah écoute et déjà
sur la question des sorties c'est la
question des sorties je vais répondre à
votre question sur le financement mais
déjà sur le fond sur le dispositif
il faut en terminer avec le couperet des
18 ans l'a
terminée terminée et donc il ya déjà eu
des avancées à l'assemblée il ya eu des
avancées en commission au sénat vous
l'avez dit le rapporteur a inscrit un
droit au retour et on va aller encore
dessus vous allez on va suivre et on va
aller encore plus loin on va les rendre
plus loin de l'est parce que le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement qui
va consister d'une part à élargir à
systématiser l'accompagnement des jeunes
de 18 à 21 ans façon systématique voilà
et ça on va l'inscrire dans la loi et
par ailleurs à mettre en place un peu
vous parler du projet pour l'enfant une
sorte de moi j'appelle ça pour l'instant
comme ça un projet pour l'autonomie qui
va consister de façon obligatoire à ce
que état et département propose pour
chaque enfant ça se passe de projets
pour l'autonomie consistera en trois
briques briques d'accompagnement
éducatif social va poursuivre
l'accompagnement que ça s'arrête pas
comme ça du jour au lendemain une brique
et à l'hébergement parce qu'on sait que
c'est souvent quand même une pratique et
puis une brique qui consiste un volet
qui consiste à tout ce qui est
accompagnement à faire des études ou à
l'insertion professionnelle et là vous
me parler d'argent par exemple
les jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
ont déjà un accès automatique à
l'échelon 7 des bourses étudiantes ça
c'est 14 millions d'euros que l'état met
sur la table les jeunes de l'aide
sociale en france auront automatiquement
accès systématiquement au contrat
d'engagement jeunes ça c'est près de 150
millions d'euros si c'est là que ça
concerne la moitié des départements et
vous dire déjà que l'état déjà de son
côté mais parce que ça correspond à ses
compétences à sa responsabilité je les
recevrai coca dont 20 mois mais j'ai
toujours dit que protection de l'enfance
chacun devait être au rendez vous de ses
propres responsabilités et que les
défaillances elle était parfois liés au
département
qui défaillent m mais aussi parce que
l'état n'était pas en
parle on s'en sert qu'au delà des
questions d'argent autre projet de loi
c'est une véritable révolution
culturelle qui propose en fait quand
vous parlez du tiers digne de confiance
de la séparation des fratries du
couperet à 18 ans là on n'est pas au
delà des questions d'argent on est dans
des choses qui ont dysfonctionné pendant
des années ça paraît le bon sens
pourtant c'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant les années qui ont conduit à des
maltraitances elles sont connues on n'a
pas su résorber est-ce que vous allez
réussir avec cette loi à remettre tout
ça sur la table rebattent les cartes
encore autrement dit est-ce que vous
allez pouvoir aussi faire en sorte que
tous les gens qui travaillent dans les
services sociaux que ce soit du côté de
l'état ou des départements change aussi
leur façon de faire et de voir et
prendre en charge ces enfants en fait
c'est l'ambition de ce texte vous avez
parlé de révolution culturelle je sais
pas si j'aurais été jusqu'à là mais en
tout cas c'est l'ambition de ce texte de
mettre un terme effectivement un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements que l'on
constate jusqu'à présent et qui ont qui
date d'il ya des décennies en fait il
est chez les choses qu'on traîne depuis
extrêmement longtemps quand même
absolument absolument moi je crois qu'il
ya quelque chose de gea la question de
se renvoyer les compétences aux visages
des uns des autres je pense que ça ne
fait pas avancer le débat voilà je pense
qu'il faut qu'on reconnaisse qu en
réalité un peu à la française on a un
peu tendance à penser structure
compétences et oublié de penser
bénéficiaire final
l'enjeu justement s'excuser menacé de
mettre l'enfant c'est de mettre l'enfant
au centre et de s'organiser autour c'est
la réforme de gouvernance qui évoquait
sa part est un peu techno mais c'est
très important il ya un point à rennes
spécifique c'est celui des mineurs non
accompagnés les mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés ou secs dans l'est un
certain nombre de services sociaux des
départements sont totalement débordés
parce qu'ils doivent aussi prendre les
mineurs nations unies en charge des
enfants et donc c'est un coup terrible
et les structures sont dépassés qu'est
ce que vous pouvez faire pour résorber
aussi ou résoudre ce prof problématique
là alors d'une part l'un pour le coup
mais depuis quelques années déjà l'état
accompagne financièrement les
départements sur ce au delà la compagnie
chinoise a par exemple beaucoup de ces
jeunes qui sont accomplis reçue à
l'hôtel un plat sans encadrement sans
cela il ya un principe enfin plus qu'un
principe est d'ailleurs le rapporteur
boon va plus loin en tout cas propose un
modèle oui il va un peu plus loin que ce
qui était prévu à l'assemblée avec un
principe d'interdiction on avait déjà
posé seins mais d'interdiction des
enfants à l'hôtel et ça effectivement ça
concerne à 95% des mineurs non
accompagnés
ils étaient dix mille ce que ce
phénomène là on le connaît depuis dix
ans les enfants à l'hôtel moi j'ai
dressé pour le nombre des mineurs dans
la
position moi je moi ce texte il est co
construit avec les parlementaires et
notamment avec les représentants des
collectivités locales que sont les
sénateurs voilà il ya un certain nombre
des choses qui ont été des vraies
avancées à l'assemblée nationale le
rapporteur bonnart sur cet aspect là une
vision sensiblement différente on
travaille évidemment en parallèle avec
vous imaginez bien avec l'association
des départements de france - avec les
départements je les ai tous tous les
jours au téléphone il ya un modèle
différent qui consiste à interdire
totalement dans un délai on va voir 12
24 mois il va y avoir des débats en
séance moi je suivrai ça si
effectivement les sénateurs veulent
avancer a lancé là dessus
il ya des départements vous savez qu'ils
ont et qui ont réussi qui ont supprimé
les hôtels la moselle le nord mais pas
me dire que le nord c'est un département
facilement je parlais avec stéphane
troussel seine-saint-denis ya quinze
jours bon il avait 800 jeunes à l'hôtel
essentielle en 2001 la compagnie il en a
plus de 200 aujourd'hui d'une part parce
qu'on a moins qui sont arrivés dans
notre pays du fait de la crise qu
évident il faut le il faut leur
l'admettre et puis par ailleurs parce
que c'est il est dans cette dynamique là
parce qu'il a compris qu'on ne pouvait
plus laisser des gamins seul à l'hôtel
il ya deux dispositifs qui peuvent
exister voilà il faut les créer et on
est là pour accompagner et là aussi
financièrement j'annoncerai un
accompagnement de l'état pour
accompagner aider les départements à
s'inscrire dans cette dynamique l'an
alors apparaître la présidentielle pour
terminer on connaît ça y est un mets
propositions des différents candidats au
fur et à mesure ça arrive valérie
pécresse notamment sur la question de la
famille puisque ces sujets qui vous
intéressent tout particulièrement elle
propose des allocations familiales
universel allocation de 900 euros par an
pour toutes les familles qui feront leur
premier enfant une hausse de
l'allocation au deuxième et au troisième
enfant défiscalisation des pensions
alimentaires pour les familles
monoparentales qu'est ce que vous pensez
majeur
avec jean paul huchon gens pensent trois
choses s c'est un peu un catalogue quand
même de toutes les mesures qui traîne
depuis quelques années moi je trouve que
là je trouve que la droite a un peu de
mal à renouveler son logiciel sa petite
famille alain je suis désolé de le dire
ça ça a été ma première réaction ma
seconde réaction c'est j'ai pris ma
calculette ce que j'avais entendu dire
que ont cramé là ont cramé la grèce el
kram la caisse des asservis à la règle
cette allocation là pour le premier
enfant jusqu'au 18 ans j'ai calculé je
crois que c'est plus de 12 milliards
d'euros donc quand vous commencez à
additionner puisqu'elle propose enfin ça
a fait chauffer mon ma calculette sant
il ya une trop 2-0 tenait bon donc il ya
un moment il faudra qu'elle nous
explique
et puis je pense qu'il ya une erreur
d'analysé en fait en réalité je dis pas
que la dimension économique n'est pas
important mais il ya deux choses 1 la
corrélation entre le niveau des
allocations et star et la fécondité
parce que c'est un peu ça qui est
derrière on sait que mais c'est pas
qu'en france 1 la france est plutôt bien
positionné m'enferme dans tous les pays
et en france y compris à une baisse de
la fécondité la corrélation entre le
niveau des allocations et la fécondité
depuis 30 ans dans tous les pays de l'
ocde en fait et plus en plus ténue voilà
qu'est ce que veulent les parents
aujourd'hui ge qui parle une fois encore
que la dimension économique n'a pas
d'importance mais qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent de
globalement trois choses ils veulent
être mieux accompagnés
ce sont deux seuls
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
investit nous autant sur les 1000
premiers jours de l'enfant c'est la
raison pour laquelle on crée des
parcours mille jours pour tous les
parents avec un entretien au pré natal
au 4ème mois obligatoire remboursé par
la sécu avec un renforcement des moyens
dans les maternités avec la création
pour la première fois d'un entretien
postnatale à la 5e entre la cinquième et
la douzième semaine pour lutter contre
la dépression post partum qui touchent
100 mille femmes dans notre pays vous
savez que le suicide maternelle c'est la
deuxième cause de mortalité chez les
femmes après l'accouchement d'empreintes
de valérie pécresse a rien là dessus
deuxième chose que les français veulent
les parents c'est pouvoir mieux
concilier vie familiale et leur vie leur
vie professionnelle c'est pour ça qu'on
a doublé le congé paternité de 14 à 28
jours c'est la fois depuis la création
de congé paternité que ce congé
paternité a été allongée avec une
semaine obligatoire c'est la réforme la
plus connue la plus appréciée des
français aujourd'hui
fausse route et par ailleurs et par
ailleurs on va juste pour terminer ce
qu'il faut aussi c'est créer un service
public de la petite enfance garantir à
chaque français chaque parent un mode
d'accueil pour son enfant c'est
compliqué à faire on est en train
progressivement de le bâtir voilà c'est
ça c'est à créer les conditions
d'accueil globale favorable à l'arrivée
d'un enfant c'est ça qui peut jouer sur
le taux de natalité et cessa
qu'attendent nos concitoyens c'est ça la
politique familiale qu'on est en train
de mener depuis trois ans elle s'en est
pas rendu compte
après les dernières questions le
président de la république prendra la
parole pour une grande interview de deux
heures demain soir oui il a enregistré
dimanche est ce que vous savez ce qu'il
va nous raconter allez je suis j'en suis
désolé mais pas le monument mieux nous
faire une petite mélodie
nature non alors sage j'ai pas d'infos
jeu j'en ai quelques doutes
alors quand est-ce qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas et ses missions déjà
je ne sais pas s'il annoncera sa
candidature et je c'est une décision qui
est je suis 2es jeux des trucs c'est la
langue de bois mais c'est la réalité
c'est une décision qui n'appartient qu'à
lui
pour que le thon parole du chef de
l'état demain soir soit décompté de sa
campagne à ce qu'elle n'a pas raison de
dénoncer une campagne sous couvert de
comté présidentielle c'est à ses
traditions ses traditionnels qu'en fin
d'année comme ça le chef de l'état
prenne la parole pour s'adresser aux
français le présent la république
l'avait déjà fait l'année dernière sous
d'autres formats souvenez-vous froid qui
me contactent c'est mal même quand vous
dans l'express il avait parlé sur brut
d'ailleurs à l'époque
particulière oui enfin je suis une fois
encore c'est assez traditionnel par un
chef de l'état s'adresser aux français
en fin d'année comme ça je pense que les
présidents précédents la belle avait
aussi fait d'ailleurs temps de regarder
été enregistrée dimanche à les diffuser
le soir valérie pécresse devait faire
une grande émission bien fou
d'inquiétude
dans la majorité présidentielle
vis-à-vis la candidature de valérie
pécresse franchement je pense pas que la
date a été fixée en fonction de ce que
j'aille pécresse sur une autre chaîne
coïncidence mais je ne doute pas que ça
se rende interview de valérie pécresse
race à reprogrammer un autre jour il
reste pas mal de soirées d'ici à
l'élection présidentielle valérie
pécresse aura tout loisir de s'exprimer
sur la question dorian sur la
concurrence de valérie pécresse
vis-à-vis des manuels macron qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
puis 6 quand même est-ce qu'elle n'est
pas en train de ramener l électorat de
droite qu'emmanuel mac ont écouté les
conquérir
écoutez franchement déjà déjà mais je
suis pas encore hyper au clair sur le
positionnement politique et réelle de
valérie pécresse pour l'instant barakzaï
un petit écart tellement quand même
entre vous avez beaucoup parlé de michel
barnier donc que je respecte plus tôt
qui était qui bénéficie du soutien de
bernard gones dernier d'un côté et puis
eric ciotti qui quand même semble avec
ses 40% au second tour la sphère qui
m'ont étonné non très sincèrement je
pensais pas qu'il serait aussi haut et
qui donc va peser dé facto sur le
positionnement politique de valérie
pécresse qui va me risque donc d'être
ramené un peu plus vert vert vers sa
droite donc non je n'ai pas trop
d'inquiétude tout enfin j'ai envie de
vous dire
enfin nous pour l'instant on bosse
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure nous a
demandé le président de la république
voyez on a ouvert beaucoup de dossiers
merci de m'avoir invité pour en évoquer
quelques uns ce matin et je pense que
une des meilleures façons pour le
président de la république de se faire
il y ainsi les candidats c'est que nous
fassions ce que nous avions dit que nous
ferons et que nous allions jusqu'au bout
nous travaillons jusqu'au bout pour les
français voilà c'est ce qu'on s'évertue
à faire merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin
[Musique]